depuis 2000 16 50 mille personnes
influentes à travers le monde seraient
les cibles potentielles d'espionnage via
leur smartphone
les victimes seraient des politiques des
avocats des patrons des militants des
droits de l'homme des journalistes
voici la révélation choc d'une enquête
conjointe de 17 médias internationaux
basés sur une liste fuite est obtenu par
forbidden stories et amnesty
international les pays commanditaires
sont au moins au nombre de 10 des états
dont le pouvoir est décrit comme
autoritaire pour espionner leurs cibles
ces nations ont eu recours à pegasus un
logiciel espion mise au point par nso
group une société de surveillance
israélienne
cet outil très efficace s'infiltre dans
les smartphones par les failles dans les
systèmes d'exploitation ios ou android
et de là ils récupèrent tout photos
contacts conversation téléphonique email
sms messages cryptés y compris whatsapp
signaler nous télégramme et rendez vous
compte la france n'a pas été épargnée
par ce big brother très sournois
l'hexagone n'est pas client de henné
sommet quelques journalistes français
dont edwy plenel le fondateur de
mediapart ont été surveillés le
consortium forbidden stories nous a
avertis voilà plusieurs semaines que
edwy plenel directeur de mediapart et
moi même avions été ciblés par le
logiciel pegasus de la société
israélienne nso pour le compte de
services marocains
edwy plenel avait en effet affiché sa
solidarité avec le mouvement populaire
du rif
dix mille personnes entourées été les
cibles de cet espionnage au maroc dont
de nombreux journalistes d'opposition
mediapart a porté plainte les médias les
enquêteurs sur 180 confrères de la liste
ont analysé 67 téléphone de journalistes
37 d'entre eux portent les traces de
l'infection par pegasus certains
journalistes espionnés se sont fait
emprisonner passé à tabac prendre dans
des poursuites judiciaires aberrante ont
dû fuir leur pays est né son groupe vend
ses logiciels aux services de
renseignement de justice et au
département militaire de 40 et à
l'entreprise de surveillance divers
y'a tout usage détourné de ses services
mais elle se dégage de toute
responsabilité concernant l'usagé les
données dans un communiqué elle ne soit
dénoncé des accusations fausses et
allégations trompeuses
n è se prétend lutter exclusivement
contre la criminalité et le terrorisme
et se targue eux mêmes devraient pour la
sûreté publique dans les six derniers
mois nos produits ont été utilisés pour
contrer plusieurs projets d'attentats de
grande ampleur en europe
utilisant des voitures ou des kamikazes
en toute modestie je peux dire que des
milliers de personnes doivent leur vie à
nos employés tiens donc et pourtant les
traces détecté sur les téléphones
analysé correspondent avec les dates
entrée sur la liste fuité et les médias
soulignent depuis plusieurs années la bu
continuelle de cette entreprise des
surveillances de pegasus pourrait même
aider certains états a éliminé des
citoyens en 2018 déjà un dissident
saoudien porté plainte contre elle et
sow qui selon lui auraient espionné ses
conversations avec jamal khashoggi le
journaliste assassiné au consulat
d'arabie saoudite d'istanbul
amnesty international deux émirati
espionner et même la messagerie whatsapp
ont lancé une procédure contre
l'entreprise israélienne leur mandat le
maroc l'inde et la hongrie ont nié avoir
eu recours à pegasus pour surveiller les
noms présents sur la liste les autres
pays n'ont pas commenté mais les
réactions fleury l'onu via un communiqué
a annoncé souhaiter une meilleure
régulation des technologies de
surveillance du côté de la france la
réaction du porte-parole du gouvernement
restent d'une mollesse absolue ces faits
sont extrêmement choquant des faits qui
s'ils sont avérés sont extrêmement
graves il va y avoir évidemment des
enquêtes des éclaircissements demandés
et de nouvelles révélations seront
faites ces prochains jours avec l'espoir
que ces techniques de cyber espionnage
qui prolifèrent aujourd'hui aux côtés de
m haies saut soit encadré avant que nous
soyons tous espionnés et réduit au
silence